six one seven eight three zero 4750
let's go to our next caller from the
to15 area code who's calling today from
two one five how you doing David is uh
Michael from Philadelphia hey Michael uh
actually I was out I had a comment about
the canis own hearing yesterday - yeah
but being black and hare hare' say that
white national and white nationalism
isn't a thing was so disgusting though
like like if you look at the news like
you like new field pilot Beeson once a
month now like what happened in New
Orleans I mean New Zealand and then we
had what happened back in 2015 with the
Dylan roof yeah we shot the church and
all that and the harris data and her
being black like it let me ask you this
because you said that as someone who's
black those comments were disgusting
when you see someone like Candace Owens
urging you know she has this blech sit
movement black exit from the Democratic
Party thing and she claims that black
people overwhelmingly support Democrats
not because of any policy stuff but
because they've been effectively been
been brainwashed how do you react to
that what do you well is is that is it
condescending for her to be asserting
that in some way yeah I heard it like
say that showed that how out of touch
she is with the black community like
like Bob by the most part like people
vote their policies like the reason why
I don't vote Republicans said they don't
offer me nothing yeah I vote Democrats
because I like to think they talking
about for her to say didn't say they're
almost like you are voting Democratic
Club Democrats because we're going here
now is like that's not the reason why
most people do that
do you know sorry I was gonna say do you
do you know about anyone who has
actually followed her in this black suit
movement not personally no yeah
personally no I mean I don't really
think I mean II black doing all of our
because like when she go through she
goes around the talk to people she's not
talking to but she's probably a roomful
like you know people I'm so glad you
said that I'm so glad you said that
because one of the you know she she's
part of Turning Point USA and I get it
she has this show and they
brought in like I saw she had an
interview with a black gay conservative
and she asked him what was what was more
difficult in the black community coming
out as gay or coming out as conservative
and he said Oh coming out as
conservative was much tougher but these
are like hand-picked interviews for the
most part I think you're spot on which
is her audience is not black Democrats
she's just not talking to the people
that she claims need to leave the
Democratic Party right I heard she wants
to be see you and like she's tired of
like no you turn on said she talked but
they wasn't really going for it
I wish I could come in though for that
like you know they're educated they know
like the Republican ways not the way
that America needs to go on to it and
we're gonna progress you can't be on the
same level with developing nations in
the world well said thank you so much
for the call really appreciate hearing
from you no problem thank you David all
right take it easy
hope to hear from you again thank you